wie genau können im nhm stoffe in der
krebstherapie helfen jahres ein ganz
interessantes thema die beiden deutschen
und firmen die sich in diesem bereich
sehr bewegen bayer antic und korrekt die
jetzt mit den entwicklungen so kroner
vakzinen bekannt geworden sind sind ja
eigentlich gegründet worden um
impfstoffe zu machen
die krebspatienten dabei helfen sollen
ihr immunsystem gegen den krebs
einzusetzen
was man dabei bei den krebs therapien
gerne machen möchte ist dass man die
genetischen veränderungen die typisch
für die krebserkrankung 1 in der
patienten sind danach untersucht welche
davon immunstimulierende eigenschaften
haben und dass man diesen patienten dann
praktisch den für sie maßgeschneiderten
impfstoff in form einer solchen rna
herstellt in der korona penny verrät
alles ganz schnell gegangen in der
krebsforschung dauert das alles ein
bisschen länger in was für einem
zeitrahmen kann man damit rechnen dass
so was vielleicht auch bei krebs
funktionieren könnte
ja sie müssen sich vorstellen dass für
die korona impfung praktisch der gleiche
impfstoff für alle patienten
funktioniert und insofern hat man das
dann eben praktisch innerhalb jetzt
eines jahres sehr schnell machen können
also ich kann mich zum beispiel erinnern
dass es bei einer der firmen genau 62
tage gedauert hat von der sauberkeit der
sequenz bis zur ersten impfung im
patienten das heißt das ging dann
innerhalb von zwei monaten
wenn sie jetzt für patienten einen
patientenindividuellen impfstoffs machen
kann der nicht in der gleichen weise in
einer klinischen studie erprobt werden
das heißt das ganze verfahren muss
sozusagen in form einer plattform
zugelassen werden das heißt sie müssen
eine ganze serie von solchen impfstoffen
herstellen und sollte sagen überprüfen
ob das für viele patienten auch auf die
gleiche weise funktioniert und das kann
natürlich einige jahre in anspruch
nehmen bis die klinischen studien dann
tatsächlich erfolgreich durchgeführt
worden sind mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei der schau dir das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren